today's guest is a she's blind man I'm
gonna be honest with you if you think
she's not blind you're nuts Saturdays
guest is is a woman who's she's like
kind of like the Amelia kind of sight
heart kind of she's just that pioneer
you know she's that she's that peep and
bad girl so she is man oh I'm talking
about but she also is a voice-over
actress she is a teacher she works with
people who have suffered from the same
thing she suffers from today's guest is
blind and I've always wanted to meet
somebody that's blind and sit down with
them and so I'm really grateful already
ladies and gentlemen the talented and
lovely Tanya Milosevic
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just sitting over here right now
talking about doing anything really it's
a lot yeah just drinking some water kind
of have some notes but I'm not really
looking at um and is it fun for you when
people like kind of describe to you what
they're doing around you or do you feel
like it's helpful sometimes I can tell
by audio cues so for example I could
hear you opening your water bottle and
taking a swig mm-hmm so but yeah
especially sometimes if I can't tell by
someone's tone I'll ask are you this or
that or did it interpret this correctly
but you know once in a while usually
people's voices are expressive so I can
tell hmm and so you are a hundred
percent blind like you've always been
blind actually I have retinopathy of
prematurity so I was born sighted hmm it
was just that I was premature two months
and had to sit in the incubator for a
couple months and then the oxygen extra
oxygen detached my retinas so I'd have
some surgeries to reattach and I was
very lucky to be able to come to the
u.s. from Serbia whereas from and have
those reattached somewhat here in the US
here in the u.s. yeah dr. rosy like how
blind are you they're like if I had to
guess like like do you feel pretty blind
Oh total I mean it I have enough vision
to get me into trouble like it's about
twenty two thousand and one eye and
twenty seven hundred and the other so
every time I have a laser surgery
because I developed glaucoma due to the
scar tissue after my surgeries initially
the laser surgeries that I do or did
every couple of years haven't done one
in a while
thankfully those reduce my acuity each
time and there is a risk that I can go
totally blind in in my both of my eyes
are one of them depending when you say
acuity what does that mean
I mean like what I can see how well I
can see things so the clarity and the
detail that I pick up for example if I
say I have 22,000
you can see it 20 feet or rather what
you can see at 2,000 feet I can see at
20 feet so you know you let's say you
have better distance vision mm-hmm
the clarity of your vision is a lot more
detailed and all-encompassing so your
field is a lot wider than mine
- tunnel vision which means my field is
10 degrees okay so a lot of times like I
hear about people that are colorblind
and to me that seems like honestly like
kind of a bunch of [ __ ] do you feel
like that I mean I think colorblind is
definitely a thing there are people that
are born colorblind where their hues are
like gray black and white and that's all
they can really see they have different
monochrome tones but to call it
colorblind like I feel like it should be
like do you ever feel like yeah let's
call it cult like let's call it like hey
kind of confused you know like yeah
let's don't go all the way to blind like
blind seems like almost something that
should be a little bit more reserved for
people that actually can't really see
that well do you guys is there any vibe
like that in the in the blind community
where there's like kind of like you know
like darkness beef with like people that
are colorblind or anything like that um
in terms of that not that I've noticed
but people do get upset over the terms
visually impaired versus totally blind
some people like to say that they have a
visual impairment or they are low vision
depending on what their acuity is and
how much whether or not they can read
print so for example someone that can
see traffic lights outside in the
daytime they can read signs they can
read print and navigate maybe with
minimal use of a cane they call them
high high partials mm-hmm and then there
are people who are totally blind or who
are lights who have some light
perception and we we do like to
categorize ourselves some of us in in
those various categories but then there
are a lot of people for the sake of the
public who just say even if they're not
totally blind I'm blind and just call it
a day because really confused yeah yeah
cuz I don't want to be a hi parcel that
sounds like somebody that's trying to be
fancy to me like I would be I know it
does yeah
look guys I'm out okay hi partial so say
it with you go away yeah hi parcel
sounds like somebody that's like in one
of those um like that movie with Katniss
Everdeen you know oh yes I'm a high
partial put me near the cornucopia first
yeah the best weapons
yes ounds like because there's a lot of
hi parcels even just in regular do
especially in Hollywood this place is
full of hi parcels oh man
Jesus it's really uh it's a little bit
creepy almost out here so do you like so
if I reach across the table right now
and touch your hand like if you put your
hand out right mhm okay can you tell by
like touching my hand like like how old
you feel like I am or do you interesting
question I've actually never got that
well because I could imagine your senses
or better than monitor this is my
perception is that your senses are way
better than mine so so I'm thinking like
you know do you is your sense of touch
like at a level that I couldn't couldn't
even imagine you know um so I would say
that it's all in how much you use it I
think anyone is capable of developing
sense of touch more or hearing vision
etc so you focus mainly on what you see
around you and maybe don't focus as much
on audio cues because you don't need
them as much you can you can see what's
around you and that sends compensates
for the others that is your primary
sense for me I would say mainly my
hearing is my primary and of course I
read Braille so I use touch for that but
what's interesting is I would say my
sense of touch and my index fingers is
better than my sense of touching my
other fingers because I use that for
Braille and have developed that
sensitivity in those fingers do you
learn something then about like almost
you feel like so then with that being
said like still your sense of touching
your index fingers is much more acute
because you use it for Braille use
that's your main fingers used for
Braille right I would say so do you then
do you think that this could be possible
that if somebody used their shoulder for
Braille for long enough that they would
be able to develop a sense of how to
read even or their toes there are there
are folks that like I've seen Oh toe off
so you talking about people that are
just toeing off
or they use their toes to read yeah
that's a guy like a guy like that sounds
like a line of guy would use on a girl
you know like hey I can use my toes to
read oh yeah I like a pick-up line at a
bar yeah let me read your shirt I can
use my toes you know yeah I mean they do
make Braille shirts right and it says
don't read me or don't touch me or
something in Braille beeping you realize
that sticker I know that says you're
driving too close and it's in Braille
and it's on like nice would you make
sense really I'd love to see that yeah
that close you got a back off you got a
problem you're gonna get run over
yeah but so you say you feel like for
you your sense of hearing is really
acute I would say I've developed it more
so and I pay attention to minut sounds
whereas that kind of goes both ways
because in dance music my boyfriend
loves to put up the music really loud
because it you know it sometimes like
especially working out or something
so there are in dance music high-pitched
buzzing noises it almost sound like a
like an electric chair
you know and it's painful like the
louder it is the painful it is and I
just have this like instinctual ah you
know recoil reaction put my hands over
my ears know anything's it's the
funniest thing ever who makes some of
the most painful music out there because
obviously you have very acute senses
there is a German band that I've heard I
think it's called Republic won or
something oh yeah and it is I I'm just I
sit there I'm like no what about an
American artist maybe I mean that makes
them really really you know just some
real junk like I mean I'm thinking for
me it's Nicki Minaj oh yeah some of her
songs are interesting that I could see
that these are a band or something that
kind of you're like hmm I would say
probably some of the the death metal
bands like I and I used to love death
metal so I'm not trying to rag on them
here but um Cannibal Corpse
oh yeah the example they got something
it's just painful high notes and in the
solos they don't want you to live
through the songs no that sounds like no
they want you to become a cannibal
corpse yeah they have ulterior it sound
like they have really ulterior motives
yeah is there it's just so interesting
so it almost it seeps so - your sense of
hearing to me would almost be like
almost seemed like a superpower almost a
little bit I don't know I mean if I were
daredevil and had a weapon in my cane
that'd be awesome but yeah yeah no I
wouldn't I wouldn't say it's it's that
good but it does certainly help in
picking up cues and what's going on in
the environment environment around me so
especially for navigation I used my
sense of hearing let's say there's a
waterfall that I know I'll have to pass
or keep behind me as I'm traveling
forward and then there's an ice cream
parlor and they play particular music
and there are smells associated all of
that not only triggers memory to help
you like sort of map it out in your head
but it gives you a constant that you can
rely on as you're as you're traveling or
even when you're watching films without
audio description do you feel like a
detective a little bit then like when
everyday when you wake up do you feel
like almost like Inspector Gadget a
little because you got it kind of like
that would be cool
hey maybe I'll make my mornings a little
easier especially when the week drags on
and I just want the weekend to be there
so I can enjoy and record and have fun
yeah I'll try that that's a good
suggestion but do you feel like like I'm
just trying to think of what it's like
to not like you know to be to not have
sight to be blind to be sight impaired
like I'm trying to think of like if my
brain would wake up every day and ever
in the world would seem like more
vibrant yeah is that what it seems like
it can certainly especially if you're
looking forward to the day and you're in
a in a great mood it can definitely
seemed filled with with a lot of
different things it can get a little
overwhelming sometimes we're not having
sight you mean yeah if you're in a loud
environment for example oh yeah like
being at a bar or a club even at a
convention or
all right like a Chelsea Handler yeah
listen to her yeah yeah yeah sorry
just somehow slips out of me but um so
so places like that because why there's
too much going on there's too much and
sometimes what I do what helps in those
situations because it's hard to navigate
if first of all if there's flashing
lights like at a carnival loud music
loud a lot of people talking it's hard
to orient yourself so what I'll do is
I'll like if I'm standing somewhere
waiting to navigate I will put my hand
on something that doesn't move some
solid object like a chair or a table and
just stand there and kind of listen and
try to figure out where stuff is hmm
or if possible navigate when the
environment is quiet map it out for
myself and then it's not so you know
crazy yeah
but the dog actually my dog here the boo
boo
very good at navigating outside so if
I'm a loud restaurant which happens a
lot you know a lot of music I'll just
say okay now boo outside outside find
the door find the door come on come on
come on do you want a treat let's go and
she did she finds the door and she helps
you leave mm-hmm and um she's very
beautiful oh thank you
and she also I noticed that she has very
beautiful eyes yeah she wears makeup for
me does she not she has not real makeup
but she's got markings around her eyes
and it looks like eyeliner that's what
I've been told it's so funny when you
and I met her a few minutes ago when you
introduced me the first hand is better I
never noticed about I mean I've seen
some animals with pretty eyes and stuff
before they got smushy the caddis and
beautiful eyes here's an Instagram page
but um but she has beautiful eyes like
a.m. it's almost at first I was like
holy smokes like today did you guys swap
eyes or something like she's got some
like it's just crazy it's almost like
that you were carting around a real set
of freaking peepers right there on Naboo
do some animals do you get a different
sense from certain animals and other
animals I'm just wondering like if you
can get different senses than I can from
from animals do you mean like bonding
type or your attentions yeah do some
animals feel to you
like like what is it seem like to you oh
they're very lovey usually they pick up
on our emotions in our body language as
well as facial expressions really well
and the body positioning like where
their tail is low is positioned or how
how they're laying sometimes or even the
enthusiasm of how they greet us those
can tell us a lot about how they're
feeling and I find myself talking to her
like she's a real person you know all
the time but she's with me everywhere I
go so it's so interesting you know and
now what about a cat do you have the
same interactions with a cat I used to
have a cat when I was a kid and I had a
very you know solid bond with her she
was an outdoor cat and she would sleep
on my bed with me sometimes or I used to
carry her by her neck I guess as a kid
my mom told me oh yeah which is not the
right way to carry a cat but she never
cared like she was so sweet and chill
she didn't feel alive it sounds I know
right that was a little bit just didn't
care but animals got along with me just
fine do you get different vibes like can
you get a different intuition from say
like a snake or a frog do you feel like
they have I'm just trying to think oh
actually snakes kind of freak me out I
used to like them as a kid Dave but then
when they start wrapping around you the
more you know about them and how easy it
is for them to just choke you to death
hmm the scarier they are and more
intimidating I think reptiles are hard
to read and some people have a knack for
it mmm me personally nope I have no idea
I just always feel like I could be in
danger of getting I don't know squeezed
to death any moments right there's no
ability to kind of know what they're
thinking no feeling not with reptiles
for me it's so interesting yeah yeah
yeah I can't read them they're so cold
and detached and it's all about what
they want but a cat also I feel now that
I'm a dolt they're okay I'll Pat them
but yeah I don't trust them very much
I'm more of a dog person yeah no I agree
I saw to catch the other day sharing a
cigarette outside of my building you
know that's the greatness
I knew they were up to no good you know
yeah
and yeah thank you I think I'm just like
I was thinking about this last night I
was like when I was young one of my
favorite the one of the first people I
ever remember meeting was this kid named
Doug Hugh ball that I went to school
with and I was in the second grade and
he had a stutter and it was the most
fascinating thing like I'd ever heard
like because everybody I'd heard talked
the same like everybody just talked you
know oh yeah so when he suddenly had
like this voice that was like it was he
was like a like he was like I was like
like an instrument a little more you
know is this so it was unique and I was
like oh man this is the best and I
remember I started impersonating him and
then the teacher at school thought that
I was making fun of him right but I was
and I just wanted I wanted to be like
different kind of like he was you know I
wanted to be I don't know I just yeah
well it just seems so unique to me and
so I think then I've always just had
like this just this affinity for what it
would be like to have something unique
like no vision or or a unique like you
know like they have a guy sometimes you
see on the internet who doesn't have any
arms and legs and he like does all these
stunts and everything you know this
little yet it's kind of little bucket he
kind of bad boy you know so I guess like
I was thinking last night I was like I
wonder if your imagination is different
than mine actually I'm very imaginative
I'm a huge fan of horror particularly
and horror films horror films horror
books music radio dramas that are
involved with horror for example like
the white vault for instance pasteurize
and check them out they're awesome are
they oh yeah they're full and scholar
productions actually that one you're
doing voiceover yes right okay so I mean
I've got to plug these shows cuz I'm so
excited about them know of course and
we're gonna plug them to whenever we
whenever we bring the we'll do an intro
for the show later yeah that will make
sure to plug in but yeah so so first
let's talk about imagination a little
Naboo sorry about that it's okay
so there was just a knock at the door we
don't I'm not sure who it was but so
Nabu lets you know when he does she
alert barks he does actually what's
funny
well I work at Perkins School for the
Blind at the Perkins library and at work
if somebody comes by my office she's
like whew like she gets all worked up
she barks maybe five six times but quick
just to let me know they're there can
you tell the tone even down to the
smallest level in her bark like if she's
trying new mm-hmm if she's trying to be
like alert you or if she's trying to let
them know that you're there or like you
able to different note like notice
different levels of like intonation that
she has in her voice
yes I am for example if she's startled
she'll do a very quick short
high-pitched bark and then if somebody
comes by that she doesn't like she'll
get up and walk over to them just be
like mm-hmm
you know just like ground when I bring
this gift Wayne over all just growl yeah
how dare you Oh get them out of here oh
yeah dude and he was a bit of a deviant
but yeah your imagination like I was
thinking last night I was like my
imagination is almost kind of limited by
my colors you know I wonder if like my
imagination got caged up you know
because it's it's like limited a little
bit by knowing like what a lot of
different colors are and how the world
is kind of or how the society we live in
is kind of built you know yeah well you
can you can definitely expand all that
like noticing smells whenever you're
somewhere let's say out and about
walking by shops or something you can
smell all the different things coming
out of shop and sometimes you can even
tell where you are based on the smell so
just starting to notice that in your own
life to actually meditation exercises
help with that mindfulness mm-hmm
where you you notice um having this
thought or I'm thinking about what I
need to do but I'm just gonna let it go
and think about you know let's see where
my thoughts go naturally and what do I
notice around me
like something like a sound of a fan can
be soothing kind of white noise
intermittent can cause your brain to
focus harder on an arm a task that
you're working on and that's all
mindfulness so doing something like that
can help you get to that same level that
I'm that I'm mentioning where you're
discussing all the five senses and how
they implement how they work together to
create that multi-sensory picture of
where you're at yeah so but in terms of
imagination actually my friend and I as
teenagers we used to get on the phone
and this is when people actually used to
talk on the phone instead of texting and
instagramming and twit tweeting to each
other
we would sit on the phone for hours I
kid you not and sometimes we would do
online mud games you know where you
would that is like a dandy sort of
online mm-hmm and now that Dungeons &
Dragons you're saying right yeah you can
play these how because so you know how
online they have a graphics system and
multiplayer versus cetera this is all
done through command line so you modify
it by going in you bring up like a
command line box kind of like we used to
do with das right HTML we can enter in
code mm-hmm and you you enter textual
text commands like the old text
adventures used to be in the 90s on the
old ah systems and you would enter
commands and then a lot of the games now
you can insert a sound pack which would
take the place of some of those longer
command line prompts and we can listen
to sound effects in 3d space and figure
out where at environments and and things
like that spells all of those have
sounds related to them oh I see so by
adding in sound packs you're able to get
like a more of an experience where you
can actually enjoy a multi-sensory like
a video game experience now so with
virtual reality kind of looming does
that seem very exciting to like yes
blind community oh yes
deep end games actually produced one
called perception and it's about this
main character was blind and she's got
to go to
grandfather's house go through it and
solve the mystery of what happened to
him and how he died and it starts off
it's fully voice-acted it's 3d audio
space and I contacted them I was like
hey guys you're awesome like how do I
play this they're just like oh uh we we
believe it's accessible let us know you
know so I've got to get my nephew to
help me out here
and what is it called again I'm gonna
write that down perception perception
and sounds really really interest oh
yeah oh yeah the trailers are amazing
and the voice acting is spot-on and so
when you are listening to these types of
things I mean you get everything from
sound right I mean you're not able to
yes and and then you have like some kind
of extra I believe it's her or it's like
an extra voice that tells you where
you're where you are and how many meters
away from something you're standing and
that's all that would additionally help
you navigate and there are also iOS
virtual reality games out there mhm and
you're you eight like so a virtual
reality game like for me I would take
the head the vide the visual set like
the goggles mm-hm and put them over my
head over my eyes and then I you know I
would have the headphones on I would
listen to the experience but also be
able to see it for you what does that
experience like it's more just sound
based it's more sound based where you
would have the set of headphones on and
everything would be in binaural audio
which is a simulated 3d space
oh wow okay so it's a different type of
audio specifically for people that are
hearing impaired they actually make it
for anyone who wants to play the game a
lot of these have graphical interfaces
built-in so anyone can play them the
goal is just to make it fully accessible
for all and which is great because if
you have a little bit of vision you
might be able to see the graphic in a
graphical interface as well I see
there's a YouTube video of a guy that
has a lot more vision than I than I do I
would say he plays a Star Wars virtual
reality game and is able to move the the
lander around successfully on his own
without dying I see and he gets super
excited about it obviously and but your
imagination like so you have color in
your imagination
you're imagining things yeah I'm losing
color perception a little bit so my
ability to tell shades apart like
Bluegreen for example if they're close
or if purple is close to blue sometimes
it's hard to tell but I do imagine it
for what color I have that will enter
into it and of course it goes into
dreams as well so can your dog tell like
if someone is lying I wish you think she
can tell if someone is trustworthy or
not it's sort of like that saying where
you believe kids you can't fool a baby
or a dog mmm you know that's saying I'm
probably seeing it wrong here but that's
what we do here at home she can
certainly tell if someone's not
trustworthy she doesn't like them she
gets a bad vibe and maybe will bark a
little bit more if they show up and
doesn't trust him doesn't really want to
go near them avoids them we were on the
bike path once just walking I was with a
couple people and there was some guy
that was walking down the bike path for
some reason she didn't like him so she
pulled us way over into the grass went
around him and just kind of stopped as
he walked by cuz he was like oh hi there
oh wow so I said hi and she just stood
there and just didn't want to move until
he walked by just staring at him and you
were able to just kind of feel that vibe
from her take those cues 100% yep
because she was standing very still and
kind of tense right and you trust her
wholeheartedly like there's a there's no
there's no like unless it probably comes
to a treat I'm guessing there is no
misconception about what her intentions
are yeah it's she's pretty spot-on
trustworthy dog that's pretty cool huh
yeah my first service dog was like that
too but this one is a lot more
protective of me mm-hmm not to the point
where she'll bite or attack I do think
if I was being mugged or someone was was
trying to attack me in some way she
would step in and try to bite them at
that point because she's protective but
she wouldn't just bite somebody right
now do you feel like you said you like
horror films yes sir
to me it feels like you're already like
in the dark a lot like I would feel
I feel like it would be double scary hey
you want it you want to promote me for
in the dark I'm happy to be on that ship
is that a show it's a show it's a blind
protagonist on the CW wow I don't even
know that yeah that was a pun okay
perfect
no I know that yeah no you - voiceover
working I wanna I want to learn more
about the about the characters you play
in those but yeah I'm just curious I
guess is like you know what um like
what's what why the horror genre do you
feel like I'm wondering just is there
any correlation between what your daily
kind of existence or experience what the
world is and if you think it ties into
liking that genre um that's a good
question I think it ties into I love
adrenaline rush and just that whole
fight-or-flight response where but is it
ever I feel like everything will be in a
general and rusty like a B it's true
when you're crossing a street if a car
just comes out of nowhere you're like oh
my god I'm gonna die but in this case
you're able to like you like every 10
minutes is the X Games I feel like for
you it can be depending on where you're
at whether or not you're getting you
know assistance or if you know where you
are like when you're lost oh my god
that's anxiety provoking yeah especially
at night
and what if your dad wasn't there what
if naba wasn't there yeah that would be
harder I'd have to figure it out with my
cane and it would be a lot slower of a
process I'd have to slowly map out my
surroundings and find let's say the
nearest street crossing and then the
nearest building and ask for help like
just go in I've done that before
oh I'm sure yeah like lyft uber drivers
a lot of drivers don't speak the
language very well they don't understand
a lot like what do you mean the language
of sight or the language English English
yeah oh yeah there's a lot of dudes and
then I think any language a couple of
them I know right yeah I've got some
guys that don't speak anything dude they
just but you pick a letter of the
alphabet out of a hat they have no idea
what you talking exactly they can't read
sign that's yeah I know I know it's
frustrating
yeah I went on the Transfer Center for
the Arts once and they dropped me off
like the guy had no idea he's like
building
building I'm like sir I need to go to
the chomps root Center for the Arts
here's where it is like this is what it
looks like there's a sign right outside
it's huge you can't miss it
I'll tell you if I can see it I'll tell
you he's like a building
oh no building no no building I'm like
yeah obviously I can tell it as well
that there's no built we're in a parking
lot like where come on yes no building
I'm like alright see you later you're
getting a three star rating sorry buddy
do you find that um do you find that so
more about that horror genre sorry let
me think cuz I'm not kind of a thinker
but more about the horror genre so is it
because you know when you said that like
crossing a street I can't even imagine
not being able to see and crossing a
street right on red is not a fun thing
and then I would just be so scared like
what you don't know if the guy over to
your left is like not paying attention
or you know sorry
and a lot of people are on their phones
so it's a more of a risk for anyone
crossing now does can you feel that vibe
if somebody's on their phone is I feel
like a different vibe than somebody just
sitting there like say if I'm just
sitting here yeah unfortunately not I
can't I can't tell that at all it just
looks like they're sitting waiting to
proceed at the next cycle right what
does it feel like can you get a feeling
from it that mom's not really like I
can't tell unless the person kind of
pulls forward and then stops and then
pulls forward then I can tell that
they're they're distracted okay but I
don't really get any intuitive feelings
from it mainly what my intuition works
on for me or works well with me is is
let's say a friend wants to go on a job
interview and they tell me oh I'm going
on a job interview at noon what do you
think am I going to do well and I'll
think okay so I'll put what I know about
this person style as well as the person
they're going to see and what their
history with this person was what they
told me their previous interaction was
and then my gut instinct and I'll kind
of come up with an intuitive I think
you'll do great or I'm not really sure
this is gonna work out but this will
lead to other opportunities for you and
it usually turns out to be that way do
you feel like more of a computer than a
person
sometime oh yeah oh yeah that's that's
actually very accurate because social
interaction can be nerve-wracking I have
a little bit of social anxiety in
certain situations yeah and I like the
pre-programmed like five questions when
you start a conversation how are you you
know what do you do you know where do
you live those those five like small
talk questions that probably helps give
you more of a world a little bit of a
world to start with and like yeah it
helps give you some information helps
give you yeah it does but it's also as a
person who can't make eye contact it is
very difficult if you're in a group to
find when is a good time to jump into
the conversation and add something to it
so it's like being stoned then because
yeah I've been high sometimes and I'm
standing there and then yeah I don't
know when to jump in and then everybody
leaves you know you're like where'd you
call if you wanted a ride but do you
feel like a damsel in distress sometimes
I feel like if I saw like if there's a
woman walking around who's who's blind
and I'm I feel like is she like a city
like not a sitting duck but is she is
she like a city like do you feel like a
potential victim possibly ever uh so I
did more so when I was at like I went to
school at Simmons for undergrad and what
is that oh that's a sorry that's a
school in Boston it's it's an all-girls
school okay but in that area like the
Fenway area of Boston as you know the
Red Sox play there it's like a lot of
events a lot of drunk people on
alcoholism a lot so a little unnerving
like I've had people just go you know
when I'm walking by or something yeah
we're like hey baby you wanna like you
wanna talk to me or whatever I'm just
like no so I had my service dog that
made me feel a lot better and then I
took self-defense and I took Kempo
karate so it's like I know the basics I
know
shove my fingers into somebody's eye
sockets like that will stop them right
away or you know just shove your fingers
up their nostrils Oh
boom or into their neck into their atoms
off of their guys you can reach them oh
yes you just know the basic defensive
strategies and it really gives you a lot
of confidence like you feel better
traveling at night in that area but
other than that do you feel like a
particular site impair right now I'm you
keep using different terms because I
don't know what I'm no you're good but
do you do you like my intentions are
good I mean yeah I don't sometimes I get
vibes from people where I feel like they
may not have great intentions and I'll
just cut the conversation short and move
on okay yeah I don't want you to feel
like that from me be fun no no okay no I
know that you you know like I know you
do voice acting on a youtube podcasting
or in that universe yeah but I mean I
yeah I just I've never got to spend time
with someone that couldn't see you know
so I've just always been curious
no and no question is a bad question you
know everything is is fine like I don't
get offended or anything I'm happy to
try to give you a slice into into what
it's like yeah although every person who
is blind has a different perspective on
their life depending on when that where
they're at really oh yes now when you
say where do you mean where they're at
in what so in terms of like how long
they've been blind when they lost their
vision whether or not they have some
usable vision or if they were born with
no vision people who are born with no
vision their concept development is
depending on who taught them and what
school system they're at they may or may
not have concepts of different things
like like what certain animals look like
for example and so were you on that
scale you have some concept some
concepts yeah there are some things like
for example when I read in books where
it says so-and-so's eyes sparkled with
amusement I'm like what does that mean
how did they Sparkle does it like do
they have more tears in their eyes
because they were so amused and so the
light was catching off of the tears and
glistening on their eyes but I have
actually like one time I was holding my
my niece when she was a baby
nose look
in her eyes and I could see the sparkle
it was like the first time I could see
that it was so cool
oh yeah babies have more of it to me
that thing is like it's like a light
behind somebody's eyes that's like not
like a moisture thing to me it's just my
perception of it yeah and it's like
something of like peacefulness or
comfort so I think you see that or like
excitement can sometimes like flare it
up in people mm-hmm in younger people I
think excitement flares it up in older
people
I think sentiment or like nostalgia
nostalgia that's a great one joy like
things like that really kind of yes
happiness things that kind of mold like
a fluffier emotion Oh like positively I
think those are things that would add
like a sparkle to somebody's I mean
that's sweet you know yeah yeah I just
like now what about like like would you
close your eyes ever or use like there's
no point in it oh well because I have
some vision yeah I do I close my eyes
like what I'm gonna go to sleep or let's
say sometimes I'll be light-sensitive so
if I don't have my sunglasses and it's
super bright out I'm on the beach and
the Sun is glaring off the sand throwing
up lights oh so I close my eyes so what
does that feel like for you that just
feels like an intent it's just uh an
intense like what whiteness kind of
color it kind of yeah kind of like well
because I mean I can see a general
colors so let's say I'm looking at the
yellow sand and it's just a lot of light
it kind of washes everything out and
it's unless I'm squinting really hard
and my eyes start tearing I'm unable to
really make a lot of other things out
all right for long before my eyes start
to water so at that point closing them
is the best but it is similar to just
this glaring white field of light and
then I close them and it's red because
you know that's when you close your eyes
that's what you see if there's it's
bright mmm and now what if I put like a
woman like 50 feet away from you
mmm-hmm and I put your mother 50 feet
away from you right yeah do you think
you would know the difference between
the two of them if they talked yes if
they didn't say anything at all so if I
could but can you feel that you're I'm
just trying to get an idea if this makes
any sense can you feel like that your
mother is clear like you know I'm saying
kind of through the feeling-wise no
because like I don't have any extra sort
of intuitive sense of who is who unless
I have some additional cues okay so it
would depend on the contrast the
lighting like it was it was decently lit
but no glare let's say like an overcast
day cloudy day and somebody was 50 feet
but the background was not complex so I
wouldn't get confused by trees or houses
are a few very specific hmm exactly so
just like just like nothing almost right
yeah so let's say they were standing on
the beach right they were standing on
sand and there was nothing else to
clutter the background I would be able
to see them but then if I could preview
whose clothing or outfits looked like
what and if they had very contrasting
compared to each other outfits I'd be
able to tell okay that's my mom standing
on the left and this is mystery person
number one on the right you know because
they're wearing a white shirt on the
right my mom's wearing a red shirt right
right like so a little more clues you
have so it's a lot of clues a lot of
puzzle pieces so the detective analogy
earlier was good so it's a lot of clues
when you can't see mm-hmm a lot of cues
and things you put together do you find
that or do you get any sense that
certain cultures are friendlier than
other oh certainly like in the UK and
here in the US and Germany they're very
inclusive of people with disabilities in
general and the UK in particular has
made a lot of wonderful strides like
audio description captioning for example
Wow they audio describe like double the
amount that we do and that we're
mandating other chaddy mm-hmm I mean
they are chatty yeah they've been
drinking haha but now I'm making a joke
there certainly so they have so you're
saying that the UK really is kind of the
leader in that sort of world I would say
the UK Germany
you know they've done a lot to to
include people and even Switzerland and
I would say and then the US definitely I
hope it continues to go that way and
other countries in Europe like for
example where I'm from Serbia they are
not as inclusive they're a little behind
the times yeah but they're getting there
I know Perkins is working with them
through Perkins international to try to
teach teachers from there how to better
instruct their students and include them
get them prepared for mainstream work
and then in India for example they're
working hard to get some of the I guess
poorer families communities to include
people with disabilities in the
workforce so it's getting there it's
just our the first world countries have
to help the third world hmm to get their
wish in the problem is also have we
can't get half the first world people to
freaking to get a job already go to work
we need to help our own people it must
be do you can you tell like when you get
a vibe we're going around someone who
can see who has all the faculties and
they're like oh they're not even trying
yes no it's okay
yes definitely have had that experience
before where people complain that they
can't find a job but they're not really
trying
laughing the unemployment you know yeah
you're like I'm like you know I'll take
any job here at this point like any
additional side gig would be welcome but
you're not what do you want me to do if
you aren't sure then you are gonna be
because the truth is that this past
weekend is brought to you by Skillshare
if you if you if you're somebody and
you're walking around you're like dang
wish I had some skills well get some
skills share is an online learning
community for creators they have 25,000
different types of classes design
business more you'll discover countless
ways to fuel your curiosity creativity
get it get excited you you ever think
find a passion in your head look inside
of your head right now what's your
passion
go up go look for it on Skillshare they
have classes in social media marketing
mobile photography creative writing
illustration this is this is it's like a
new college get the skills you want
apply them to your world you want to
learn filmmaking try low-budget
filmmaking do you know how many shape
movies are out there you could make one
tips and tricks for an indie look it's
one of the most popular courses join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for our listeners get 2 months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering this past weekend
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare dot-com slash th
EO vo in to start your two months now
that Skillshare dot-com slash Theo von
and now let's get back to this beautiful
blind episode you mentioned earlier that
you have a boyfriend is it is it I would
imagine that it's let me think about
what I think when he's also visually
impaired as he is yes well he's missing
out I'll tell you that beautiful thank
you this I'm not honey I mean I'm always
trying to hit on everybody a little bit
but at the same time I'm I would never
be disrespectful your boyfriend um oh no
no no worries um yeah I think I'll say
this for myself especially when I was
young I would probably be scared if
someone was blonde you know I would get
it yeah and I don't mean this in a
negative way I'm just trying to be
honest I would feel oh yeah y'all
probably scared I was probably you know
I didn't know what to do I with there
yeah if I go engage with them am I gonna
mess
am I gonna mess things up or something
like whatever's going on in their world
like am I going to hey you're not alone
a lot of people don't know how to
approach yeah the blindness community I
think on our end what we could do better
is communicate what what we're thinking
and how we're feeling because our body
language is a lot less like a lot of us
sit still or don't move a lot because we
don't have the concept of you know like
for example Italians like they talk with
their hands like this and whatever for
us we don't really have that as a
natural part of our lives like we don't
just circulate gesticulate yeah that's
good
and that's off-putting to others who
have that as part of their or they use
they get cues from others how they're
feeling through body language a hundred
percent yeah you get a lot of that yeah
you get clues from somebody's activity
if they're yeah just there you can get a
lot of a lot more clues yeah I don't
know how many clues it is oh yeah so it
would be good on our part to communicate
oh I'm not upset I'm just you know I'm
thinking or like I know my face probably
looks like I'm pissed off right now but
I'm just I'm spacing out or I'm not
really I'm thinking about what I have to
do it at work tomorrow I'm not pissed at
you because sometimes our facial
expressions don't match how we how we're
feeling or what we're thinking
Wow and that can be off-putting to
people also I had to be told this
because I used to sit like this where my
hands were across my stomach crossed
over myself
and that looks like you are closing or
that yeah I guess no thanks never
usually about 13 years old oh man
different times but um but to you that
see people would what clue is that given
off to people that I'm closed off and
not welcoming interactions oh yeah so
you have to sit very open like your arms
have to be out to your sides you know
I've actually read a bunch of stuff on
body language just to try to understand
the concept of it hmm
and then a lot of people also when they
shake someone's hand if they're blind
like they're just like oh god how am I
gonna do this so what I do is a person
who's blind is I'll I'll put my hand out
first so I'll be like oh nice to meet
you yeah toward the middle of my body
because you know you don't want to put
it way out to the side that just kind of
looks weird and you're exuding
friendliness by taking the cue first and
taking the the awkwardness out of the
situation so it's just we we have to
educate ourselves on body language and
make it more comfortable I love how you
have just an ability I mean it's and
this is just such a neat gift that you
see that you probably I think as a
person to seem to have is to recognize
your part in things like you know
instead of saying like Oh everybody
needs to do this but people could do
this it's like oh the blind community or
as a person that sight impaired we could
do this these are things it's like it we
all we all can sub-skills yes but we all
can always help our own situation even
if we think something else is like
really impairing us yeah there's always
like our own part in it kill them with
kindness that's the way to do it yeah if
you can if you're grumpy that day just
don't talk
yeah just kill them oh my god you got me
into the horror feel and say yeah yeah
making me think of the dark arts and you
know it must be so I mean you could if
you if you're blond do you feel like
everybody could be a killer hmm
sometimes like there's so much more
opportunity for you to think there are
people that are killers like I can see
people I'm like awed are not killers you
know yeah but for you I feel like you
could always be like fantasizing there's
somebody in the distance with like a bow
and arrow or something unique oh yeah
sometimes you can freak yourself out
that way wow like oh my god a bunch of
zombies are gonna break into this car
and they're gonna eat me yeah like your
imagination must be able yeah does your
imagination is it very active it's very
active Wow yeah like if I watch a horror
film like for example I just saw the
haunted that the series on Netflix have
you seen it no I have oh it's scary yes
a little too real
and so horror films that district
thought of this because they have so
many more sound cues they do they do and
the sound design is amazing yeah because
it's yeah it's it's trying to build up
in emotion whereas a lot of other things
aren't really doing that they're just
kind of telling trails story like Point
Blank
yeah like bird box for example with
Sandra Bullock yeah super amazing sound
design with the sat with the the minut
sounds that you would hear in your
environment only their exaggerated
enough just so that anyone can notice
them
and they're not as crazy with the jump
scares which gets old
yeah I agree yeah horror films come they
got they got lazy really they did yeah I
miss the old when I was young ahead
Jason Voorhees they had like Friday the
13th oh yeah some of those things
Nightmare on Elm Street yeah Michael
Myers a bit that stuff I bet no Michael
Meyer the Halloween's were really good
probably the early ones yeah yeah they
were pretty good I think they could have
done I mean this is 70s but I think they
should have made it stereo versus mono
where it's like coming out of just one
channel in the center and then the music
is stereo yeah it could have been but
you know for what it was at the time it
was really good yeah yeah oh I'd love to
see I wonder how interesting it would be
if you designed this like helped design
the sound for a horror film I bet that
would be fast it would be awesome do you
feel like we use the the skills because
that's such a unique skill that you like
a sensory ability to connect to a sound
at a level that I couldn't do yeah you
know because yours your senses in that
space are more acute I wouldn't want to
make it 5.1 surround like most movies
are anyway where it surrounds you like
the you wouldn't want to I would
I would want to yes and I would want to
make the so you know how when people are
on camera the the actors on like audio
drama they are in the center unless
they're coming on to set from another
room that's when you would hear them off
to the side but otherwise they're coming
from the center so both channels
directly boom in front of you because
the cameras focusing on them what I
would want to do is create like a
virtual reality horror movie where you
walk through like a fly on the wall and
you get to hear these things happening
and the people move around you in space
mm-hmm like 5.1 surround sound because
that would make it more real especially
if things were happening to you and if
you can make it like a 4d sensory
experience where not only do you have
the movie and the headphones around
everything's happening around you but
you would smell things like blood for
example yeah or maybe you'd have props
to use along with the movie like like
let's say you have to kill the killer
you'd be given a prop gun oh wow
something like that would be actually
feeling you in half yeah yeah oh that
would draw so many audiences I think
just maybe you're talking like five day
maybe yeah one you need another day go
all out yeah and it's just so yeah it's
like well I wonder do don't do people
does Hollywood come and tap into the
blonde community to learn more about
sound or are there groups that do that
it seems like it would be almost like a
gold miner they would that you know they
would go to a mine that has the value in
it is there any like connection to my
knowledge no but I do know that they
have experts and consultants that they
go to for example for the movie bird box
I know they went to a couple of people
who are blind to inquire about how
things were being portrayed like Braille
for example signage and things I'm not
sure on the sound design if they went to
someone who's blind but I am aware of a
BBC the BBC does like 3d audio radio
dramas for their for their programming
and they did employ someone who was
totally blind as a sound designer that
that is one example that I can think of
and I know there are sound designers out
there I just don't know if Hollywood
collaborates but that would be great
that's the idea yeah cuz you guys are
like hawks almost do you feel like a
bird is there an animal you feel like a
little bit you kind of relate to a
little bit more like is there an animal
you feel in the world and you're like oh
that animal has a very similar
experience maybe to mine a little bit ah
has that ever happening there it can be
a known just I'm just trying to wonder
besides an AI I said I would say maybe
like an artificial intelligence a
computer you know oh I see machine you
know cyborg because you feel a lot of
times things are more like a machine
almost mhm
like you have to get Clues yeah you get
information and then you're able to
build more of a world which is the same
way people do programming yes and you
can reprogram your brain so for example
like habits you don't like you can
reprogram yourself to not like those
habits that you loved what now you must
have a much more because you're right
there at the atomic
but but you have more of an access to
the atomic level of that than I would
because I'm out here in this comfort
zone you know just a damn Sugar lizard
out here whereas you're down there
working with the building blocks more
inside of your senses sometimes so is it
easy for you to to do that - like
reprogram yourself I'm just fascinated
with psychology as a person and I think
that's just more of my own interest then
my ability to work with it but if you
believe something it's it's funny how
the more you believe something the more
it is so if you put something out there
into the universe and say oh I want this
to be this way it will or if you have a
negative a sense of something that the
self-fulfilling prophecy will happen as
well which is unfortunate that's but it
seems like you get what you put out
there so in terms of my ability to
improve my programming and adjust its I
have to constantly believe that it will
work if I stop believing it's gonna work
or I give up I get lazy it's not gonna
work it's just going to go back to where
it was is it it would feel like it would
be easier for you to give up because you
don't it just feels like it would be
easier does it feel like that to you
ever or you don't know what I'm talking
about is I understand what I'm saying
can I do like the with depression with
getting down or yeah yes oh yeah yeah it
certainly can like in my early 20s
through my mid 20s it was a factor in my
life as well as high school because I
had a lot of challenges with math
getting through math I was um just to
quickly mention it was mainstream so I
went to public school and keeping up
with calculus or precalc trig all that
yeah when the teacher was understanding
and helpful it was it was okay I was
able to work with them the later the
more advanced the concepts got the less
time the general ed teachers had to work
with me on it after school before school
etc and I would fall behind sometimes my
grades would drop and I was huge into
having good grades yeah I didn't want to
fail out or not pass the M casts or you
know even the SATs I needed it was
important to get a good score to get it
go to a good school Wow and so I pushed
myself and wasn't always
sitting in math and felt like okay what
am I going to do you know got really
depressed and also the fact that it was
harder to make friends was making it
then only adds to it worse but when I
got a dog man it was so much easier to
make friends people love dogs as long as
you're putting the attention on the dog
and not yourself to begin with people
feel a lot more comfortable hmm so I use
that as my kind of helpful strategy and
working through depression I have a
couple of really good friends who we're
going through similar times we help each
other out we were there for each other
and it's important to recognize when
you're down let yourself be down and
then find a way to pull yourself out
mine was creativity just being as
creative as possible
yeah yeah and you can see that even in
your work I mean it seems like you
really go beyond what people would what
an everyday person would expect of a
blind person like you kind of want to
kind of change the norm a little bit
yeah technology helps us level the
playing field yeah it's interesting cuz
you work and now in voiceover you are
character actress right yes yeah I do a
lot of accents and different characters
put myself into them
yeah one of the best pieces of advice I
ever came across with acting as I don't
know if you agree with this since you're
an actor yourself and stand-up comedian
I found that when they say that when you
put yourself into whatever character
you're playing whether or not you're
dressing it up with an accent or not if
you put your own truth into it it is
what they're looking for
hmm just heard that today from Gianni
actually who really yeah he's actually
our actor on set who here is Gianni and
he's uh yeah he was just in a film and
um and yeah he was just helping me with
some lines earlier and he literally said
that like half-hour for you got here
some grass funny yes it's a small law so
yeah it's a small circle of truth right
here so is that and how did you get into
that did you stumbled into it really yes
thank you Stephen King I went to my
local library to pick out I used to get
books on tape oh yeah
good oh yeah we should get movies at the
library you remember that oh yeah oh
yeah I used to borrow those too yeah
force my family to watch all these
horror films that they hate it it's some
dark arts dude I would be so scared if I
had a blind child who brought him horror
films all the time they don't want to
piss me off the with your family every
day did your family ever get cuz here's
a nothing how you making me think some
people would be scared of blind people
Oh
oh my god yeah like I don't know way
yeah but like in a way yeah like in a
way where like like maybe you're
actually just pretending and you're
working for the other side or something
oh yeah agent lined or something yeah
yeah like what if they're just you know
see they would make really good Russian
spies right yeah no I'm just kidding no
I'm yeah I think something but I could
see especially at a young age is people
being very I guess like it must move
what some people must you must be able
to just see a clear line and people like
some people are just so empathic
probably and so like did you see a lot
of that growing up or do you see a lot
of that more of as an adult
um that's let's see so as a kid I did
notice that the teachers around me did
try their best to accommodate a lot of
them just weren't sure what I needed I
was a dual learner so used large print
on a video magnifier and Braille and so
they were always like uh so you use
print but how were supposed to what do
you what do you exactly need yeah I was
so good so so they were like empathetic
to a point but they were also stressed
out because they're like oh god we have
like 30 kids and we have to accommodate
one kid oh my god what am I gonna do but
the kids at that age the younger the
better they were they were more
accepting but then middle school high
school they were just like I see you
later yeah you know but in college as an
adult I found a mixture of both where
people were really mature and cool about
it and interested to know and it helped
that I went to a liberal school as well
but yes Simmons you said Simmons yeah
now a lot of pervy dudes just try
bang a blind gal or what honestly well
there's a lot of that too I can imagine
yet because there's a lot of guys you
know kind of like different types of
styles of stuff you know I just wonder
if if that did you get some of that I
did I got some of that kind of thing
where people were trying to flirt with
me but a lot of the time I didn't pick
up on it because I'm like who would want
to flirt with me right like you know I
guess my confidence was not as as solid
at that point so I was just like nobody
likes me why would anybody want to talk
to me oh man that must have been such a
tough feeling huh yeah it was kind of
contributed to the depression for a bit
there but that happens all teenagers
sort of go through that whole angsty
period in their lives really true my
life sucks everyone hates me nobody
understands me why am I even here yeah
but I didn't pick up on it like friends
would tell me oh so once I was totally
hitting on you I'd be like really how do
you get that way to get that from well
the comments and whatever they were
staring at him like really okay that's
that's cool not interested but that's
cool and in college that would you get
some more pervy type of dudes I could
see a guy that's been like hey or even a
guy not pervy just very honest like hey
I've always wanted to make love to a
blind woman is this something you'd be
interested in yeah I I got like when I
did the online dating thing for a bit
and put on my profile because I was sick
of dealing with people that found out
that I was blind and then were like see
you later just go stood so I was like
not done with this crap like I'm just
gonna post right here that I'm visually
impaired if you don't like it like don't
even bother blind AF that's what I put
on there no blind ever after - you know
- [ __ ] no yeah this to be you know I'm
saying like might as well also be
progressively you know I'm like now am i
blind dude I'm so [ __ ] blind
exactly John Cena like you can't see you
know blind is [ __ ] until I drink so I
have guys that came in like that so you
dated online and so then you just put
blind I did yeah and it was that easier
it was honestly people just knew and
they weren't like all weird
yeah about it when they found
out I mean I met up with a couple of
them and then was just like yeah now
good you know yeah that's basically I
think that is online dating for everyone
I think you described that yeah
everybody's experience yeah a lot of
times man you meet up and then yeah yeah
you're just like interesting I met a
mathematician one time and he talked
about math the entire time I'm like dude
you do realize I hate math right
I really hate maths like let's just talk
about random stuff and then go our
separate ways because I'm never gonna
contact you again to be honest and
you're like man I wish I was blind and
that would be great that's how I feel
like sometimes I'm like gosh I wish
sometimes I wish you know what's crazy
is I wish and I guess it's a selfish
thing to say to somebody that can't that
has that sight-impaired but that
sometimes I wish I just could shut down
some of the sensory overload well see if
your computer you can just go visual or
ocular sensors off and just turn it off
for the moment that would be great but
I'm waiting for the days when not only
the singularity happens but we're able
to get a chip and plan it that can't be
hacked Apple you listening I know that
you know that way we can turn off senses
we don't want for the time being oh wow
that could be plausible sense huh
self-driving cars are things so I I
don't see why not
with this could help a lot of people out
do you feel sometimes that you have more
of an intuitive nough stew
I don't even know what but maybe how
people are feeling sometimes yeah like
are there are the intuitions that you
that you just if you had to just trust
your own and trust your own instincts or
something other things that you what can
you do better than people that can see
that and maybe they could do it it's
like a job interview they could do they
did they may be able to do it better but
they're not able to recognize it because
they don't live in the same space that
you do like is there yeah I know what
you mean um and not even in a
braggadocious way but what do you feel
like you have more of an insight into or
more of a ability to do than people that
are almost
overwhelmed with sight or this that or
that have to see all the time yeah I
would say focusing on one task in our
technology-driven
a DD age it's impossible for people to
focus on anything longer than three
seconds we're kind of like dory the
goldfish right oh yes from Finding Nemo
she's her memories like oh yeah yeah
remember yeah cute comic comedian
reference right but um we we tend to get
distracted very easily two different
things and get bored quick I would say
that if I'm interested in something I
can focus on it until I'm done with that
so whether it is a particular song or a
particular movie I like to I really
enjoy personally art and I don't know if
this is related to me being blind or if
this is just a personality thing but I
love admiring people's art whether it is
through something auditory art like tap
dancing or going to the Nutcracker and
listening to an audio described version
of the performance I can really enjoy
all the nuances of the work and the time
that went into practicing and practicing
and completely solidifying their
performance well get to that point like
Broadway plays for example I love them I
can pick up on people's voice so much
going on mm-hmm
there's so much quite a specific
Hamilton is hard to follow I could tell
you that yeah but it's when you're about
on Twitter too I feel you but I imagine
that it's great I haven't been but it is
but I a Lion King was the last time Oh
Broadway musical that I went to but I
could imagine that because there's a lot
of a lot of stuff going on but it's very
specific and it's organized so portray
something to portray a show to portray a
story yeah art imitates life and you're
able to put that together mm-hmm
yeah I love it it's it's brilliant and
in general just being able to focus on
one thing or another or pick up on
things others don't
I've noticed that we we tend to pick up
on other sensory cues that folks did it
of maybe someone who's sighted who's
around us did not because they were
focusing on what the person was wearing
totally you
Oh so-and-so you know I love their
hairstyle or whatever dress that was
this brand and this material I'm like I
have no idea what you're talking about
but you know their voice expressed this
or their footsteps you know they sounded
kind of less confident because their
gait was stumbly or not even or
what-have-you so wow it's so crazy I
feel like you have like such a I guess
just like you have such you're that the
ability to hear and be able to interpret
things so much it just feels like such a
unique skill kind of and anyone can
develop it like if you know and and
obviously this is not something I would
ever wish upon anyone but let's say you
lost your vision temporarily due to
something some surgery or what have you
I love surgery too yeah I do surgery
that's awesome I could see it happen I
listened to your last episode where you
were discussing you were thinking about
being a doctor oh yeah and then they
brought you in and they just kind of
dumped you into it all that must've been
horrible
Oh Tom Segura yeah yeah but yeah surgery
I mean watching it is interesting yeah
yeah I guess I mean that kind of stuff
kind of creeps me out I mean I think you
know if you're in a horror flicks it
might be more your vibe you know
oh yeah one of my colleagues had a major
abdominal surgery and he was supposed to
go to sleep under local but as you know
it never works like it's supposed to and
he woke up and he was awake during the
whole thing he was traumatized poor guy
it was just jeepers yeah awful yeah just
kind of mosey around during your own
lobotomy that sounds awful yeah it
sounds risky yeah definitely for your
psyche yeah it sounds risky for your
psyche anyone can develop those skills
of recognizing nuance and sound but so
then we gets lazy with our sight then we
get or because because we have sight we
yes you you use it as your primary sight
lazy right later you take a visual oh
yes you don't yeah you don't you know
sound cues cuz you can see it yeah it
makes sense yeah
make sense I guess but it also it makes
it makes me almost forget about the
other senses that I have sometimes I get
so just used to looking at the picture
you know but actually for Halloween one
of my favorite games to play with
friends was blindfold everybody and then
stick their hands and bowls of stuff and
tell them oh this is worms when it's
actually spaghetti yeah like peeled
grapes oh you want to hold an eyeball so
does everything does the world feel a
little bit haunted since you can't see
that much like is everything feel kind
of like is it spooky or does it feel
like kind of like like you're in Sound
of Music or like what does it feel like
I guess it depends on my frame of mind
hmm
so if I freaked myself out in some way
by watching something or I don't know
hearing some story that really sticks
with me and I'm out and about by myself
and like oh my god I'm gonna get
murdered this is really creepy and then
try to come up sometimes I'll even try
to come up with a story or like even if
I do get startled I'm like okay how did
I do that like what did I do to get
startled I'm gonna need this for voice
acting so try to bring it over bring
over those those natural reactions and
keep it in mind like how do I react and
I'll watch movies and I'll pay attention
to the actors how they do it and what
makes them a good performer and try to
adopt it mmm so I kind of multitask at
all-but Sound of Music if I'm really
excited about something like I'll tell
you when I got this opportunity I was so
excited the last couple of days have
been like oh my god the world is awesome
oh that's awesome hear that yeah that's
cool
yeah we were really excited to you know
you've been trying to find somebody um
honestly we've been trying to find a
blind person for a while really yeah so
we need more behind people I think hey I
can recommend some more people if you
need if we have follow-up questions I
think has been very interesting um we
have a couple of video calls that came
in as well sure so let's put our
headphones on
and this first one comes from Marco hi
Marco from New Zealand my question is if
there's one thing that she comes across
every day that sighted people don't
understand that they could change to
help her what would that be gang gang
gang gang Marco thank you that's a good
question honey what do you think about
that so should I leave these on our
ticket yeah well it will leave a mark
you have a couple more we have a couple
that uh okay we had a little we had a
ton actually we got we procured a couple
so one thing that sighted people could
do in my opinion that would help is if
they could just let us know what
specifically makes them uncomfortable in
situations and what we could do better
to to sort of put them at ease mmm that
would be helpful for us because then it
wouldn't be all on us to try figure out
how to how to make people comfortable
but then also if we should get better
about asking for help I think if we need
it but then I guess sighted people
should trust us to know what we need and
when we need help and just to let them
know what it is and also don't be afraid
to ask questions that's one of the
things a lot of people are uncomfortable
with which I I get I mean I would feel
the same way I don't know much about
mobility issues so if I were talking to
someone with mobility issues I would
feel like I'm gonna fund them I don't
want to ask anything that's rude or
ignorant and it's hard because you're
making yourself vulnerable by asking but
my thought is just just put it out there
if you have any questions go for it yeah
the other thing is giving directions I
think people need to get way better oh
yeah it's over there it's it's that way
I'm sorry where am i right to my left
and then I just start pointing in every
cardinal direction north south east or
west which which direction yeah oh
they're always like you go a couple
blocks to you uh smell a little bit of
skirt steak and then take a
like what nice you're like what are you
on yeah that's a great question it's
interesting cuz it just sounds like
really communication you know do you
feel like in the times that we're in
right now or like not the times but as
the times that like the media likes to
make it feel like we're in yeah with
like social justice warriors and
everybody get a getting offended that
people are people I've I've noticed our
less feel less comfortable asking
questions that can actually be helpful
do you notice any of that like people
are more worried about offending you
than they are about engaging with you
all the time it's just easier not to
engage then risk offending someone and
getting sued right everyone's afraid of
getting sued and that must come down at
suffering in even in your community
because or not in that in this lawsuit
way but just or maybe so but also just
that you know you need more
communication yes I think communication
for us is key because we may not be able
to tell body language or eye contact
whether the person is interested in
communicating with us or interacting so
just talking and literally talking
everything out yeah which doesn't sound
intuitive at all because you guys are
used to body language and just kind of
hey I'm pointing at you hey you know
gesturing and what-have-you
so that's a big gap right there and if
we all just used our words a lot more
instead of memes and and emojis I think
we get more cuts we need to go back to
the 90s I know I know yeah back when
there's some real actually information I
know I know I missed that yeah it's
interesting and now we have movies with
all texting like the whole movie is
texting and skyping right yeah it's like
what is that even about it is yeah
that's regular life I know um what else
do we have
let's take another question that came in
this is actually a patreon question so
it was a rich it comes from a Dalton
Wyndham mm-hmm he said if you had
perfect vision for just one day what
would you do during that time ooh
that's awesome probably
hmm look at the coral reef or go to go
to all the tourist attractions like the
Grand Canyon and maybe climb a mountain
look at the view
all the things that are visual I would
probably want to want to do like all the
traditional and maybe even oh I'd
probably want to be on set for a day and
just act without having to worry about
not meeting my mark mmm I'd want to
incorporate that somewhere in that day
so yeah you take that worry out of your
field and then you can just be even more
free probably yeah yeah yeah do some
on-camera work with perfect vision would
be awesome yeah that's cool yeah that is
a good one
anything else Nick they came and he
liked yeah this this was a frequently
asked one that we had two that were
really frequent um here's the first one
what up Thea what up Tonia Gang Gang
anyway I was wondering real quick
Tonia you know
do you have dreams and we have dreams do
you see things do you just hear things
like I mean I guess seeing things I
don't know it might sound ignorant to
say that but I just I've often wondered
what happens when blind people dream do
you have like no interesting yeah what
are your dreams like kind of are they
yeah so first of all I want to
compliment you on the stereo recording
you had there that was cool and yeah I I
do dream and see things in my dreams
like I have I wouldn't say my sight as
any better some of my friends that have
had more site before tell me that their
dreams are a lot more vivid and visual
so everyone is different with that and
the more people you ask the different
responses you're going to get but for me
it's I can see things the same as in
real life but the difference is that my
brain kind of knows where everything is
so it's like I'll know what everything
looks like even though my vision isn't
better I'll know where everything's
placed and it's all already mapped in my
head so it's like intuitively just
knowing where stuff is which is cool
also I'm I am able to hear things the
same way and I haven't mastered lucid
dreaming I'm trying to that would be
awesome if I could just control my
dreams change them up make you know fly
like I was able to do that once where I
dreamed that I was in an airplane and
the top came off kind of like a hot
dream really yes God and we're going up
and about up and down some mountains in
the top it was like a convertible
airplane yeah and it was like on clouds
they were like cotton candy from the
circus oh wow it was just kind of
floating on clouds and the top of it
opened and then I sort of was like I
wonder what would happen if I jumped out
yeah without being scared jumped out and
I put my hands out to my sides and I was
just floating and flying around the
plane and along the clouds sitting on
them and floating on clouds it was
awesome that was the only time I was
able to control it but mmm
I'm working on it dream journals they're
thing yeah I'm trying to get that nah
wet dreams they have wet dreams in it if
you're blonde if you have a did it have
I don't do women even have wet dreams uh
yeah I would say so I mean yeah that's a
thing it it happens once in a while like
when you either don't expect it or if
you really like somebody yeah it's just
like it comes up or a lot of the times
what used to happen for me as a teenager
is like it would be like some burning
building or something crazy like out of
terminator and then the random guy would
show up and be like do you want to live
or you want to die let's go yeah you
know and then just go from there and
then I'd wake up like just as I was
getting into their cars like what really
why is this happening why I don't have
to wake up right now yeah oh yeah yeah
I've had something like that yeah I mean
not with the guy but with a woman you
know right yeah what else do we have
here we got one more video question
let's do and honestly this was probably
sent in by 12 different peoples from
Andy Ferguson yo whisker Theo
Superboy Andy up in Portland Oregon
what's up and I had a question for Tanja
or
yeah great yeah it's a soft J it's a
question that has kept me up many a
nights just wondering how do you know
when you're done wiping Gang Gang mm-hmm
okay so I guess I'd say if you're going
to the bathroom if you you know if
you're going to the bathroom how do you
know when you're done wiping your body
that's kind of like the question where
people ask when you're in the shower how
do you see to shower right right well
you keep your eyes closed and you shower
anyway yeah it's it's one of those
things where you can just like you use a
bunch of toilet paper and then if you're
still not you know if you're still not
clean then you get a bidet set right
yeah and you just use that on your
toilet and you're good and it's actually
cleaner and you use less toilet paper
yeah but no it's like seriously yeah you
just you just wipe everything a couple
times and you make sure it's not
uncomfortable and if it's not you're
good yeah and you move on and yeah do a
couple extra swabs on deck exactly
I feel just like anybody else would do
yeah don't just do one time please don't
yeah you don't want to getting stuck in
the hair you know yeah yeah you gotta
tighten it up do you feel like I'm
wondering it was sex very scary since
you were sight-impaired like was that
something that was it was just kind of
regular no it was one of those things
where it was like oh I'm gonna try this
now let's do it yeah and you know it's
it's the the same again with with like
anything else you gotta communicate
about everything yeah
and just be upfront and it can be really
awkward for sure when you're like it's
your first time or whatever and you're
trying to learn your own preferences and
things it can be really awkward but you
you've got to find ways to make things
less awkward see play games I don't know
you like maybe you do some role-playing
down the line just to make things fun
you know keep things fun and you you
have if you're not into it you've just
got to be honest be like hey I do not
today I'm good yeah yeah yeah
communication mm-hmm you know it's funny
the longer that we sit here the largest
forgot that you were blind for a second
nice that's pretty crazy I don't know it
just like yeah I don't know what for
some reason it was just like I don't
know I'm just second I go I just totally
forgot about it
nothing it matters now not that I was
thinking the whole time
oh you know time you can't see Tanya
sight-impaired but I just forgot it
yeah well no it's like a tiny person or
a tiny part of who I am and it doesn't
doesn't obviously make up anyone's
identity it's just obstacle or I mean
you could think of it as an obstacle or
just a part of you that you live with
and you adapt life to but it's not
really who you are like your personality
everyone's personalities blind is
different from the others and although
there are similarities in our
experiences like finding shoppers at
stores and getting very vague
information on everything or the whole
experience where people start helping
you and you can tell after five minutes
they're just like oh you're gonna ask me
about one more thing please just go away
yeah cuz you need more information right
you have a lot of questions you do yes
like you need to know what brand it is
what the size is you know if you're
looking at shoes for example what other
styles they carry and do they have them
in your size you want to feel everything
in the store which people just get oh
that's pretty wide we're like no please
don't do that
yeah it's like a pervert at ah that's
like Jionni when he goes to one of those
bunny ranches you know he just wants to
feel everything in the store like a
better sex store nigras all the things
you and Nikki Nikki was also premature
baby on he was have no I didn't know
that so preemies yeah I was a two pound
preemie oh wow yeah and Nick came in I
think he's ready to wrestle would you
come in in no I was in I was I was
pretty heavy I was in that four to six
pound ring they called him big Nick
around the incubators yeah so but um
last question after you is is your sight
impairment is it in your eyes or is in
your brain oh that's a good one because
cortical visual impairment is now the
leading cause of blindness in the US
that's what I was thinking yeah no I'm
joking I Evan no
I have no idea what you're talking about
there oh it's a processing issue where
that is that would be classified as a
brain issue where your brain is just
unable to make sense of the images it
gets from your eyes hmm
so so there is that that's a leading
cause now but no mine has nothing to do
with the way my brain processes anything
it's it is related to my optic nerve
which connects my eyes to my brain and a
lot of the strands and those have
deteriorated hmm the more they
deteriorate due to glaucoma the less I'm
able to perceive which is why my field
of vision is so low like it's it's like
looking through a tipi tube yeah you
just see directly what's in ahead of you
the funny thing about that is though
when people run across my path like in
front of me or they step in front of me
to me it looks like they just appeared
out of thin air like they're not there
and then they're there I'm like well
thanks everyone your neighbors is like
David Blaine kinda yeah it's so
interesting um do you feel like you have
a different insider relationship with
like a higher power because you have
because of your impairment no I wouldn't
say I'm not really religious so but even
like a spiritual like do you feel like
even in your spirit like do you feel
like oh that's a good question I would
say because I'm so fascinated with the
supernatural in general I feel like I
can pick up if there is residual energy
or spirit activity or something I used
to do as a hobby like in a paranormal
investigation hell yeah you did yeah it
was so much fun
it was so much fun and and and this will
take us into you want to tell it yeah
just uh before we get out of here we'd
like to hear about your two shows yeah
yes pacifically yeah yeah so I'll
mention vast horizon which is done by
full and scholar productions Caitlyn
Travis are super talented as a team and
they also created the white vault which
I encourage you to check out but this is
creeping horror like this starts out
where it sets up the story in the
character ISM and it's this agronomist
who wakes up on its is what agronomist
and what is that like she's a scientist
she studies plants and soap so plant her
mm-hmm so she wakes up on a colony ship
and she wakes up alone like she's got a
tube down her throat and she's like oh
my god I'm dying wakes up the medical
computer gives her some basic info and
then she realizes that there are no
bodies no one else is on board she's the
only one alive on the ship that she
knows of and gets out of the Med Bay
tries to figure it out no lights
only emergency auxiliary lights are on
and she starts making contact with the
ship's AI I get to play the AI which for
me is amazing I love it because I'm so
obsessed with artificial intelligence
and I have a like an Alexa at home and
everything
oops sorry guys if I set off your
device's here that's okay we don't have
anything I mean my listeners the
listeners oh oh that's great oh I used
to go on the radio and blow a dog
whistle nice and change the whole
freaking town dude that's great yeah
that's pretty good so that sounds pretty
fascinating somebody wakes up on a ship
and nobody else is there yes exactly and
she needs to survive okay and tell us
her story through flashback you find out
how she ended up there and what her
mission is and there are many critical
things on the ship that she needs to
take care of including the incubators
you know the baby is in the nursery and
it just gets steadily creepier there
will be a couple seasons and this is all
over audio right yep this is on vast
horizon libsyn comm and the white vault
Lipson calm you can also find it on
Himalaya which is an app where which
allows you to stream podcasts you can
listen to and we'll put the links at the
we'll put the links in the information
so people can check them out
can you feel when like people are
looking at you sometimes it feels kind
of like the hair on the back of my neck
stands up mm-hmm you know it does that
tell you that we have like a unique
energy that is like used through our
eyes like is there something like I yeah
you think of your eyes just as in takers
but they're really I think it's that
that like your energy is focused on me
so I can tell that you're like directly
engaged or looking at me directly I
don't know how to put it except you feel
watched so it's
yeah it's kind of like when you watch
any ghost paranormal investigation show
like Paranormal State you know mmm
ghosts yeah I'm blanking on the the taps
team they're blanked on everything yeah
Jesus Christ
so you kinda you feel like that sense if
someone is there or they're there
watching you mm-hmm
man it sounds and now it just seems so
interesting to be blind because now you
get to live in like this constant like
horror novel or anything that happened
is that great everything is kind of
hunting you it's just such a I'm right
here with all this color and all no you
know it's just just kind of milling
around with all this frickin you know
just information that's not really as
fascinating sometimes I mean it is but I
I think what it is not I mean that in a
bad way I mean it in the sense that it's
like I forget about my other senses as
much I think yeah just being sense lazy
like I forget about like if I had to
close my eyes and sit some more for a
while and just smell or just hear mm-hmm
like what would I even pick up about the
world that I'm in try it try it it's a
lot of fun they have actually a five
senses museum exhibit in one of the
museums in Denver actually they had that
recently it was cool nobody really need
is if you went and sat somewhere like in
a specific place like in the world right
yeah and you did a thing where you just
like you told people like as an audio
tape you told people like all the sounds
that were there and so then someone
could go sit in the same place and and
just notice them yeah because that's a
thing like I wouldn't even probably
notice until someone said hey do you
hear like oh wow that is crazy I didn't
even know what that you know I think he
could just you might be able to be like
a liaison kind of a new like like a
sound Sherpa Connie you know where you
could take us up in like a you know just
kind of in just recognizing that that
sounds going on around us a lot of times
yeah absolutely you can do that with any
kind of like there are apps that will
help you I don't identify bird calls mmm
that's a big hobby oh yeah a lot of like
a Warbler - you like them yeah a Warbler
yeah yeah they're kind of cool well
like you don't like them really so so
about it yeah yeah I guess I mean I
don't like on that much but I do like
them that but yeah but but there there
are so many ways to do that I mean
there's an app called vision sim which
will simulate different visual
conditions like retinopathy prematurity
diabetic retinopathy et cetera
and the camera will you you look through
your camera at objects and you'll see
them to the degree you want to imply him
to apply that visual impairment ah so
you can adjust the slider to a hundred
percent which is total to zero percent
so try it out it's free it's made by the
Braille Institute and it's on the IR the
Apple Store what I'm saying the App
Store I will check it out I will and
we'll put the link to that as well
ten yeah we just want to thank you so
much for being here and joining us today
and and yeah I'm curious to check out
some of your uh your voiceover work
thank you and uh and just I don't know
continue to have your voice in my ears
sometimes oh absolutely I really
appreciate this opportunity and thank
you so much for having me on the show
yeah thank you just for being so candid
and just um I've really feel like I just
I kind of learned a lot of feel like and
I'm grateful for you for being willing
to let me learn you know and not being
judgmental you know and you and you're
super you had some wonderful questions
so I appreciate your your ability to ask
some thought-provoking things I hadn't
thought of either
yeah well communication right like you
said thank you so much thank you
yep
[Music]
like these leaves I must be it's gonna
take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]